Останні приготування до від'їзду:
фари, шини, міні-техогляд 40-тонної фури.
Технічних неполадок Штефан Даміан собі дозволити не може.
Адже час - це гроші. Особливо у галузі вантажоперевезень.
Спершу ми їдемо у Кетяску за 20 кілометрів звідси -
завантажимо товар для клієнта у Франції.
З Румунії 42-річний румунський далекобійник
вирушає у тривалу подорож Західною Європою.
Родичі привезли провіант та інші речі для Штефана
і допомагають завантажити усе в кабіну.
У наступні тижні фура стане домівкою Штефана.
Прощання з родиною все ще дуже емоційний момент.
Навіть за шість років роботи далекобійником ніяк не звикнеться.
Хоча Штефан Даміан уже сотні разів вирушав у різні подорожі,
ця поїздка для нього особлива.
Це перший тур за новими правилами для далекобійників у ЄС.
Відтепер водії фур зобов'язані повертатися додому кожні 3-4 тижні.
45-годинну паузу на вихідних можна проводити лише в готелі,
а не в кабіні вантажівки, як багато хто з міркувань економії робив дотепер.
Ці та інші приписи мають поліпшити умови роботи водіїв, насамперед зі Східної Європи.
Утім, самі вони вважають, що нові правила - трохи перебір.
Я особисто за повернення додому раз у вісім тижнів.
Це було б окей - раз на шість-вісім тижнів.
Звісно, я знаю, що деякі водії працюють 4-5 місяців поспіль.
Для мене це було б задовго.
Профспілки у Бухаресті занепокоєні, що нові правила негативно відобразяться
на румунській галузі автоперевезень.
Тут задіяно 60 тисяч румунських далекобійників.
Тепер багато фірм може збанкрутувати.
Їхні витрати здорожчають на 15 відсотків, щоби втілити нові правила
про регулярне повернення водіїв додому
та працевлаштувати нових працівників,  які підмінятимуть у цей час колег.
Ці витрати підвищать кінцеву ціну для клієнтів.
Це означає, що європейські конкуренти, для яких витрати
зростуть не так сильно, зможуть робити вигідніші пропозиції.
Тож деяким перевізникам доведеться поступитися місцем на ринку.
Назад на маршрут. Штефан Даміан у дорозі вже сім годин
і під'їжджає до угорського кордону.
Уже тепер тут кілометрові черги.
І з новими приписами ситуація лише погіршиться.
Адже щоразу, коли далекобійники змушені повертатися додому,
вони мусять проходити контроль на зовнішньому кордоні Шенгенської зони.
Це може тривати години, якщо не дні.
Аби залишатися конкурентоспроможними, багато румунських автоперевізників
почали відкривати свої представництва в Західній Європі.
200 тисяч людей у наступні два роки виїдуть з Румунії.
Це кількість тих, хто задіяний у галузі і переїде на роботу до Західної Європи.
І це не лише самі працівники, але й їхні родини..
Тобто кількість тих, хто залишить Румунію, буде ще більшою.
Як буде далі, Штефан Даміан поки ще сам не знає.
З такими чергами сьогодні він не встигне перетнути кордон з Угорщиною.
На питання, чи радіє він, що ЄС поліпшив для таких, як він, умови праці, замислюється.
Якщо я менше працюватиму, то зароблю відповідно менше грошей.
Можливо, лише половину.
Тому я справді замислююся, чи матиме ця робота ще сенс.
Ані домівки, ані грошей, ані сім'ї. Тоді я не бачу більше сенсу.
Нові правила вплинуть також і на водіїв з України.
Нова директива передбачає, що транспортні компанії, зареєстровані за межами Євросоюзу,
не зможуть отримати вигідніші умови, ніж компанії з ЄС.
Іншими словами, українські далекобійники теж повинні будуть
заробляти більше на території ЄС.
Незабаром ЄС почне переговори з третіми країнами щодо закріплення такихправил.